is a palestinian activist in haifa
one of the third largest cities in
israel joins us now
by skype good to have you with us what
is the sentiment like now
in haifa
well i guess first before talking about
the sentiment in haifa i think we need
to put something
uh put the record straight this is not a
civil war
we palestinians palestinians in
so-called israel today palestine 48
are colonized people this started in
1948 with the establishment of the
israeli state and the colonization of
palestine so
it's not correct to describe it as a as
a civil war it's a continuation of a
process that started long time ago
and it's manifesting itself now in
particular kind of ways
in in palestinian cities in palestine
48.
the situation is tense
there's quite a bit of fear there's
quite a lot of fear um
amongst palestinian communities because
um
at the moment we're not only facing the
kind of the violence
structured state violence by the israeli
state by its
police institutions or by its police
like in
uh by its military forces uh in in lid
but we're also seeing how um it is
armed mobs of uh of zionist organized
zionist groups
that are roaming the streets looking for
palestinians
to attack them to harm them they are
attacking palestinian institutions
palestinian businesses
the attack that you talked about in
batiyam is more like a a
a modern-day lynching of palestinians by
israeli uh by jewish israeli
citizens so the situation is tense
because the community is not only facing
organized violence it's also facing
non-organized violence
that is being protected by the state so
yesterday in haifa
while they were attacking roaming around
the streets looking for palestinians to
attack
they were being protected by the police
after they finished their attacks in the
streets
the police themselves were going into
people's homes
attacking them viciously and violently
in ways that we haven't probably seen
since military
let me let me jump in here and tell you
what what a police official told me
a short while ago he said that the
police were simply trying to keep a lid
on violence
he put it down to we have of course seen
pictures of mobs attacking people they
think are palestinians we've seen
mosques burnt
but as he put it to me this is after the
palestinians attacked a synagogue this
is after we've seen palestinians go out
and attack in in what the israelis are
describing
mob violence too
well i think we have to go back again to
the structural roots and the roots
of what is happening today it is wrong
to look at what is happening today
only from through the lengths of the
past few days
again israel is a settler colony that
has colonized palestinian land
all palestinian people are colonized
people
and they have the right to resist they
have the right to be free
and we are not free palestinian 48 of
course we carry the israeli ideas
because it was imposed upon us
but our living conditions our living
reality is not one of freedom
we are still a colonized people even if
the israeli military doesn't roam the
streets
it is the israeli police that roams the
streets and attacks palestinians
um in in very in very similar ways
but should that response include the
targeting of places of worship for
example like a synagogue
how do palestinians feel about that
should that
the palestinian reaction that you're
describing to the colonization or the
occupation
should that include targeting places of
worship like synagogues though
and civilians look i'm not here to
justify anything and i'm not a speaker
in the name of anybody people can speak
for their own selves and for their own
actions so i'm not gonna
really engage with kind of either
condemnations or acceptance i think we
just have to look at the bigger picture
here
of what is going on and why people are
resisting in the way that they are
resisting
because actually you have a state
structured violence institutionalized
violence that they're facing
and they have to resist in any way that
they deem possible um
and now what is taking place is that
people have no sense of protection
the only way for palestinians uh
citizens of israel
to protect themselves is to
self-organize and that is what has been
happening in neighborhood at the
neighborhood you see
people coming out protecting themselves
because they have nobody else to protect
them
um that this is what was happening
yesterday in white in this nurse in
haifa this is what was happening in the
neighborhood of halisa
at best it is palestinians who had to
come out
predominantly palestinian youth who had
to come out
in defense of themselves because there
was nobody else that was going to defend
them this was very similar
during the demonstrations that we saw in
the past few days
when demonstrators were attacked by the
police
excessive form of violence there was no
medical care delivered to protesters
it is we that had to self-organize and
deliver medical care
for everybody that was injured during
those protesters other than the
critically injured people who were
sent to hospital ambulances were coming
hours in in delay many people were
taken to prison over 100 people have
been arrested over the past few days in
hebrew
attacked by the police after their
arrest in the police
in the police stations on their way to
police stations okay and the only way
to defend them was
all community self-organizing right we
are running our time sorry we're going
to have to leave it there thanks so much
for your thoughts on that
thank you and the owner jeremy
bob is an intelligence analyst he joins
us
from modern by skype good to have you
with us so we've seen a number of
dynamics that kind of look different
this time around in this cycle of
conflict
let's start with the palestinian rocket
attacks
are they proving more disruptive more
deadly than in the past
yes they are um hamas has figured out
how to fire long-range rockets at tel
aviv in its central israel
up to 100 or 130 rockets in a matter of
minutes
and while the iron dome the missile
defense
to stop these rockets is still shooting
most of them down
more of them have gotten through now
than in 2014 or 2012
and that's why you've seen more israeli
civilians have been killed by these
rockets than in the past
so this is a problem that israel has to
take into account as it decides
you know what is it going to do here
what balance of military and diplomatic
means is it going to do to try to
restore
deterrence and try to restore the um
understandings
that existed you know a week or so ago
how much of this was a surprise do you
think for the israeli
well at least the israeli policy makers
if not the military and intelligence
so look the capabilities of hamas were
known we've known that they had
a certain level of rockets and israeli
intelligence is very strong in terms of
following
more developments that have happened in
2019 there were some flare-ups
and israel got to see a small bit for a
couple of days
of what hamas and islamic jihad which is
iran's proxy
can do the surprise is that hamas and
islamic jihad
wanted to have a bigger fight now and i
think there's all sorts of reasons
um the palestinians weren't able to put
together their elections
hamas feels like they're not getting
attention from the rest of the world
because of the abraham accords and all
of the other things going on in the
world
and they're trying to get attention with
certain incidents that have been
happening in east jerusalem
and that did surprise israel in the idf
they didn't expect hamas
to make such a stance at this particular
point in time
how significant is it that we've seen
now flights diverted from tel aviv
to ramon airport in the south of israel
only for rahman then to be targeted
could israel reach a position where it
has to shut down all international
flights
completely well it's very interesting in
2014 there were 40
hours where flights were shut down but
now we've lived through the coronavirus
and in the coronavirus there was a lot
longer shutdowns
so i think if flights do get shut down
and they're not completely shut down yet
they are
sending incoming planes to a different
airport but
even if there is a shutdown for a couple
of days it'll be a lot less than what
has been during the coronavirus
and you'll you'll see that if this lasts
more than a couple of days
then there could be a ground invasion
once the idf does a ground invasion
it will significantly impact hamas and
islamic jihad's capabilities to continue
their long-range rocket fire now
are these israeli policymakers having to
make
different calculations perhaps different
intelligence calculations as well
because of the communal violence the
level of communal violence which
we haven't always seen in previous
rounds
of confrontations
right the last time we saw anything like
this was in october 2000
um there were some serious incidents in
the israeli north
um and i think like that time there were
big mistakes by the police
i don't think this is the entire is
really government the police
um really are at a weak point in israel
whether it's dealing with right wing
extremists whether it's dealing with
rioters in the arab sector whether it's
dealing with a haredi ultra-orthodox
during the coronavirus there needs to be
reform of the police
it's not really an israeli-palestinian
it's really arab issue it's a problem
with the police
in general the police do seem to be
getting more of a hold
on violence both from the arab side and
from the jewish extremist side in lode
and in other cities i think you'll see
within a few days that will be
much more under control and the bigger
issue will be
will hamas stop firing rockets at tel
aviv in
central israel or will israel need to go
to a ground invasion
all right good to get your analysis on
that
yona jeremy bob thank you